we're here at the British Independent
Film Awards your fans are delighted to
see here I'm sure and will be delighted
to know what you've been up to one of
the things of course has been the Lone
Ranger what was it like doing a six-week
cowboy boot camp
I was wonderful I mean it's sort of
every boy's dream I supposed to kind of
be involved and learn to ride a horse
and shooting guns and being a cowboy and
you know what can I say it was wonderful
guitar / Lee with Johnny Depp he's not a
bad qataris and so no you can you can
play guitar with the best of them he's a
yeah I mean it was it was a wonderful
experience and we'll see what yeah it
was wonderful it was all good do you
think from your faith your character in
the film and also from this Tonto I
wouldn't like to say I I sort of I could
not speak on what we would like to see
from something all my character because
I'm being sworn to secrecy so other than
it was an amazing experience doing it
and I loved it very much I can't
possibly say mystery white boy that's
another film you got yes that's Jeff
Buckley film which I'm really excited
about we've been we've done rehearsals
in in New York and we've been playing I
think that's gonna sort of happen in
into next year sort of spring summer
time but wonderful cast amazing story
being supported by his mom as well he's
you know who's sort of producer in it
and yeah it's an incredible story
wonderful directors attached now and
yeah it's exciting but you know it's
sort of down the line slightly baby can
you tell us who you've got in terms of
director I believe that's Amy Amy burger
things but that's doing that yeah
we look forward to that on you as you
say you've got a great costume that
Gemma Arterton Olivia Thirlby as well
looking forward to working with those
guys yeah absolutely yeah they're both
great people so it's good
you